[Música]
en Caracas la capital de Venezuela se
registraron la mesa de diálogo entre el
estado colombiano y la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional lln las
negociaciones cuentan con el respaldo de
países garantes como Noruega Cuba y el
apoyo de la Iglesia Católica y la ONU
Disney recuperó a Robert dentro de su
plantilla Quien fuera parecido entre
ejecutivo durante 15 años ahora fue
nombrado consejero delegado con efecto
inmediato al cierre del viernes las
acciones de la compañía habían caído
alrededor de un 40% en lo que va del año
y solo en un día subieron alrededor del
10%.
Argentina una de las elecciones
favoritas de América Latina debutanta
Arabia Saudita en la tercera jornada del
mundial de fútbol de Qatar hay una
fuerte presión sobre el Astro Lionel
Messi a quien solo le falta una copa del
mundo en su palmarés ampliamos con
nuestro enviado especial
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes de América y el
mundo soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y es
un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
Caracas la capital venezolana que es la
sede del reinicio de los diálogos entre
el estado colombiano y la guerrilla del
Ln los países garantes Cuba Noruega y
Venezuela así como la Iglesia Católica y
representantes de Naciones Unidas se
mostraron esperanzados en el reinicio de
este proceso
diálogo de paz retomado la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional y el
estado colombiano oficializaron en
Caracas la vuelta a las negociaciones lo
hicieron con sus respectivas
delegaciones de parte del gobierno
colombiano el senador Iván Cepeda mostró
optimismo hay un ambiente de
entusiasmo de diálogo constructivo en un
comunicado de los garantes de las
negociaciones Cuban Noruega y Venezuela
y los invitados la Iglesia Católica
colombiana y la ONU también mostraron
esperanza en el proceso Venezuela además
será anfitrión el diálogo el presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro ha reconocido
el papel de Venezuela en La Paz entre
las FARC y el estado de 2016 y además
considera clave este país por la
presencia del Ln en el territorio
venezolano esto también lo piensa la ONU
que aunque no la considera una guerrilla
binacional aseguró que hay vínculos de
colaboración con el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro este lo niega también el Ln de
hecho esta misión no podía entrar en
Venezuela ni tampoco entrevistar a
miembros de la guerrilla otro de los
motivos para establecer la sede en
Venezuela lo dio a Franz 24 la analista
internacional Mirna Jones la vuelta
internacional de Nicolás maduro la
entrada de Gustavo Petro pero también lo
que va a ser la futura ascenso de
Ignacio Lula da Silva en el mes de enero
pueden dar un impulso a esa aparición
regional Venezuela haya sido clave
anteriormente para la paz en Colombia
además de acompañar en 2016 el proceso
con Dark ante a principios de la década
de 2000 contó con el apoyo y mediación
de Hugo Chávez con la extinta guerrilla
y en 1990 el presidente Carlos Andrés
Pérez apoyó la desmovilización de la
guerrilla colombiana del m-19
una avioneta cayó este lunes en una zona
Residencial de la ciudad colombiana de
Medellín el accidente dejó a los ocho
ocupantes muertos el avión se estrelló
Poco después de despegar del aeropuerto
olaya Herrera de Medellín con seis
pasajeros y dos tripulantes tenía como
destino el municipio de Pizarro en el
departamento del chocó el alcalde de
Medellín Daniel Quintero ofreció algunos
detalles sobre los hechos este avión al
momento del despegue muestra una falla
en un motor
el piloto lamentablemente no alcanza a
mantener el avión en vuelo
colisiona en este sector que es el de
Belén Rosales como he dicho se trata de
ocho personas Lamentablemente todos han
digamos los cuerpos ocho cuerpos han
sido identificados en el lugar en otras
noticias Disney anunció el regreso de
Bob Iker al frente de la compañía una
llamada de la experiencia para hacer
frente a los malos resultados económicos
de la empresa Ayer fue director
ejecutivo de Disney durante 15 años y se
retiró a finales de 2021 tras el anuncio
de su regreso las acciones de la
compañía subieron un 9,2% este lunes
alcanzando su mejor valor en dos años
el anuncio llegó por sorpresa a la sede
de California Bob iger regresa a Walt
Disney Company como director ejecutivo
menos de un año después de haberse
retirado quien fue responsable de las
adquisiciones de Pixar Marvel o Twenty
First Century Fox vuelve a petición de
los dirigentes del grupo que confían en
él para revertir la mala tendencia
económica de la compañía
la junta concluyó que dado que Disney
entra en un período cada vez más
complejo de transformación de la
industria Bob ager cuenta con una
situación única para dirigir la compañía
en este periodo crucial de este modo Bob
iger pone fin a su breve jubilación tras
15 años al frente de Disney en 2020 dejó
el cargo pero permaneció en la empresa
hasta finales de 2021 para facilitar la
transición a su sucesor bobchapeck que
ya renunció durante su corta dirección
chapex se enfrentó al cierre de los
parques debido a la pandemia a las
críticas por tardar en defender los
derechos lgbt y q más en Florida y sobre
todo a los malos resultados económicos
Bob iger rehereda ahora una situación
difícil las acciones de Disney cayeron
un 40% en lo que va de 2022 en parte por
los malos resultados del servicio de
streaming Disney Plus que ya ha generado
pérdidas de 1.500 millones de dólares en
el último trimestre a los 71 años de
edad hay que regresa por un período de
24 meses
el cual elegirá a su próximo sucesor
Vamos hasta dos a la capital de Qatar
porque este martes se vive la primera
jornada del mundial con cuatro
encuentros Uno de ellos es el debut de
la selección argentina la albi celeste
con Lionel Messi en la cabeza tiene su
primer encuentro frente a Arabia Saudita
Juan pupiales enviado especial de Franz
24 nos dio más detalles para este martes
tenemos una de las grandes atracciones
de esta copa mundo la primera de 11
jornadas con cuatro partidos al día una
de las grandes atracciones de esta copa
mundo porque los organizadores aseguran
que un aficionado o un aficionado pueden
llegar a ir hasta dos partidos al día
incluso hasta tres en esta copa mundo en
la cual no hacen falta traslados de
aviones debutar Argentina lo hace contra
Arabia Saudita un país vecino y esto con
el antecedente de lo que dijo Messi
Lionel Messi en rueda de prensa Esta
puede ser mi última copa mundo el albi
Celeste es favorita y al respecto
hablamos con algunas leyendas del fútbol
argentino que se encuentran aquí en doha
que disfruten que disfruten de este
mundial porque creo que el mundial es
una cosa única no más linda que
representara a tu país en cualquier
parte del mundo y bueno Ellos tienen
esta gran oportunidad
que que sientan todo lo que pasa por acá
porque es único es el sueño de cuando
éramos chicos eso lo saben así como los
jugadores las jugadoras también que van
a jugar el mundial el año que viene así
que ojalá que salga un gran partido y
que Argentina tengo un gran mundial no
hace tanto tanto calor Bueno ya veremos
mañana en Argentina Bueno ya veremos
pero si está así no creo que se sufra
ese martes también se estrena por el
mismo grupo de Argentina el grupo zen
México que juega contra Polonia buscando
acabar con esa maldición de siete
mundiales consecutivos sin llegar al
anciano de quinto partido a los cuartos
de final además para cerrar la jornada
de este martes se pone a prueba el
campeón Francia debuta contra Australia
para ver qué tanto le han afectado esa
Plaga de lesiones este mundial ha
generado polémicas una de las aristas
que más se han discutido es su costo
Cuánto ha gastado el emirato para
adecuar su infraestructura Y lograr que
se realice este torneo deportivo podemos
tener el informe de Rafael Pérez
es el mundial más caro de la historia
datos de la consultora de load y otras
publicaciones financieras revelan Una
cantidad exorbitante para lograr acatar
2022 al menos
220.000 millones de dólares desglosados
en estadios e infraestructura necesaria
para llevar a cabo el evento deportivo
que más pasiones mueven el mundo algo
que llama la atención en este asunto son
las ganancias tan solo 17 mil millones
de dólares de entrada para un país
pequeño con casi 3 millones de
habitantes pero realmente rico en gas
Cuál es Entonces el rédito de realizar
un evento tan caro quería abrirse al
mundo exterior por lo que asegurar la
Copa del Mundo podría verse como el
apogeo de esa ambición
Qatar 2022 es más costoso que su
antecesor Rusia 2018 multiplicado por 20
y sobrepasando con creces el realizado
en Brasil 2014 hasta el momento la
apertura no se observa en su totalidad
aspectos la cultura chocan con los
estándares occidentales a decir de
expertos todo este gasto no es más que
un lavado deportivo o es por washing dos
palabras que se aplican a las naciones
que cuentan con un cuestionado
prontuario de violaciones a los derechos
humanos o direcciones autocráticas y que
utilizan su gran poder adquisitivo para
posicionarse en el mundo con otra cara a
través del deporte un ejemplo
fundamental son los equipos europeos que
pertenecen a las cabezas coronadas del
Golfo
en Estados Unidos el presidente Joe
biden protagonizó la tradicional
ceremonia de indulto del pavo de Acción
de Gracias en la casa blanca distintas
Fuentes citan el origen de esta
tradición en la presidencia de Abraham
Lincoln con el que su hijo le habría
pedido que perdonar al animal para que
no fuera sacrificado en la comida
familiar este año byden indultó a los
pavos chocolate
es todo por el momento Les agradecemos
su sintonía
[Música]